put this away have you ever tried to
lift a limp body how hard do you think
it is
how limp can you go
consider subscribing
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
now i need a sword eventually why i
can't even lift one got moto armor on
he's ready to go and a helmet yeah oh
wow
how limp can you go
buddies how how you don't even know
you're dragging your body's easy go
ahead and drag 175 pounds it's super
easy
it's easy all right challenge complete
what else you got three all the way down
there all right here we go go live
dragging a body okay if it's dead that's
fine because if dead bodies feel no pain
but what if the subject is still alive
what this really comes down to is is
picking somebody up all right jared here
i apologize for anything that's about to
happen nico challenged me to do this
yeah i know i'm your grandma
i got a new hip in 2014. i know how to
meet your favorite pirate
like this
oh god you're back don't hurt yourself
no no no
gentlemen
laying you down to rest i gotta get to
church on sunday grandma
i can't do i can't figure it out i guess
grandma
i mean she's old
i saw the first world war one more
chance come on imagine if you will this
is your ground okay your house is on
fire you need to pick her up and carry
her out of the house so so so we're
going so we're going up and difficult
here
come on sam you can do it
[Music]
dude
me and grandma both start on fire
i'm gonna go ahead and say sam failed so
wow bold but i agree
do you have a technique to this do you
have an idea about how how you might go
about this i want to see you guys trying
to do it just trying to do it off the
couch we're talking about 175 pounds
limp this isn't nico and jake expertly
show you everything wrong with dragon no
this is everyone tries and fails this is
not going to be expertly done so the
ranger roll you start here this guy
outweighs me by 40 pounds if you
practice technique oh yeah it doesn't
and you roll around doing slow here and
you grab the leg and as you come around
here the whole body curls up onto your
back you have to do it with some gusts
though i suppose like slow all right
let's do it
all right
let's make a cutting
how do you stand up
come on grandma you got 170 pounds on
your body
gotta get you up
soon
no way you're not to do that
don't break your splinties no way
there is no way all right i'm going to
try one more technique it's not the
ranger roll
it's the classic fireman's carry
[Music]
classic fireman you ready partner
it's already impossible
you gotta get
you gotta get your your leg underneath
it
careful he's just going all the way
hearing him like a child
come on buddy
we're gonna get out of here after all
[Music]
respect for the people that know how to
do this properly yeah i have a method
are you ready too yeah you method yeah
you want to give it a shot yeah
all right jared's only for 20 more
pounds than you i'm curious
what are we doing wrong what are you
gonna do right
good luck getting up from that
you need your quads dude we're just
gonna wait let's go
it's called the final good night
this is
this is so much harder than i than i
imagined i thought it would be difficult
but i didn't
i'm sorry grandfather
[Music]
yeah that didn't work like even a little
bit
[Music]
i smell him
can you smell it
three weeks ago squarespace airdropped
me and my colleagues god rest their
souls
into the jungles of los angeles to try
and find one of the most elusive species
of our modern day internet
homo no homo we airdropped a laptop
computer n a wi-fi hotspot to see if
they could grasp the easy all-in-one
platform offered by squarespace i've
returned now three weeks later to see
the progress hopefully all of this
hasn't been in vain and my wife won't
divorce me
[Music]
these creatures are very new to
influencing if they feel over influenced
by any outsiders
they get very very aggressive must be
very silent
this is an alpha male and it's out in
the open i've got to be honest you just
don't see anything like this i'm going
to make an approach very carefully i
want to see
what he's been able to learn
hello
[Music]
hello there
come on
[Music]
they react very well to media do you
remember me
remember me
and what's this
i see
what we have here a glyph depicting
squarespace is flexible for any type of
website from his laptop make a website
about anything he desires i'd say that's
progress
using the beautiful designer
award-winning templates he has been able
to make a website say it is one of the
best ways he could have presented his
ideas this simply is a unique domain
experience once you say
simple and easy to use yeah that's very
good how did you get help
the best thing is that squarespace has
an award-winning customer service
anytime
he said yes
i'm going to need this as evidence of
our successful research
you too
can save 10 off your first purchase by
going to squarespace.com
corridor crew
to save 10 off your first purchase
if you go to squarespace.com
corridor crews
he's getting very testy i better jet
back to jail he goes all right gets to
the top and who gets the bottom is that
we're gonna do it just feet in arms yeah
right wait wait you guys think that it's
going to be just you pick them up and
haul them out of here no no you have to
get across the lava bridge the lava
bridge yeah there's a lava bridge yeah
the lava bridge oh we'll deal with that
when we get there already sam
here let's let's hit him up first
here we go
i'll get him by the armpits
i'll get him by the leg pits
here we go
you just hit the lava bridge oh no
but i think if you have another person
behind
working him up yeah then you could
probably
just
do that
yeah
then grab underneath his shoulders okay
okay like that okay okay and then
hold on
hold on they're getting they're getting
[Music]
this you good i got it just hold just
make sure it doesn't fall off all right
i'll guide them all right
method work
nico you gotta get across the lava
though don't die i'll be behind you oh
dude i didn't think about the head i
would not want to be in a situation
where you're trying to haul out
i uh
i don't exactly know what kind of
training they do to to like train for
that if it looks anything similar to
this then
god help us all yeah then god help us
yeah if there's one thing every good
producer needs is a hawaiian shirt sam
got me into it originally he knew i
would need it and as a friend
he's like hey
have a hawaiian shirt a note on hawaiian
shirts sam and i had this design printed
onto fabric and then that fabric sewn
into shirts and it's available as of
black friday on the corridor digital dot
store sam and i worked with a designer
kendra to design this little pixelated
hawaiian
thing and hidden within it our little
corridor logos so it took like two
months three months to make because we
had to have the fabric printed then the
fabric had to be sewn into shirts but
now it's here it's for sale
if you like that design we also put it
on a long sleeve portal trick shots
inspired t-shirt with the little comics
on it i really like this one we still
have things from october still available
remember the sale starts friday black
friday november 23rd as a special deal
free pins and pin backer cards that are
hand signed by each member of the crew
for orders of 60 or more and orders of
75 or more we'll get free us shipping
corridor digital dot store it helps us
make all these videos i hope you guys
like what you see
we have everyone that works here do a
training course and how to haul out a
body you get a fire department guy come
out yeah lafd
well
you have any final words nico
i think it was my favorite quarter crew
segment we filmed this fall
i agree